kantham Eric can you do a thumbs up if
you can hear us and see us
I'm making it 7:30 now Sonya are you
ready to the grass you're muted Sonya
[Music]
Marcus can you double-check for me I
know they're there I'm on the meeting
right it's Sonya you in the waiting room
or something
well if you press the link what she's
one minute okay Sonya
you're muted Daniel
sorry unmute soy Sonique you send Judea
good - Judi good in an invite to the
meeting I think she send you to name
right now
members were all but ready to start we
did want to check that the
live-streaming was working properly
which we believe it is this with your
indulgence councillor canal is not quite
arrived yet and councils good be good
Inc is on a way in
so we'll start in just a moment within
the next two minutes
Oh
in the nick of time
chairman just to let you know because he
said he's in the way hey yeah sorry I've
been having problems with the audio can
you hear me now
yes we can sorry about that guys okay
thanks Council America's still the one
that's having a problem right everyone
has a ssin so I do think we need to
start so welcome to the Development
Committee 7th of May 2020 obviously this
is a remote meeting but we are going to
be making formal decisions clearly
despite our rehearsals it's an evening
when there is going to be a little bit
of technical technical issues going on
we I will make sure that everyone all
the members are properly informed before
asking anyone to make a decision
if you can indicate by physically
putting up your hand or using one of the
icons then one of the officers will note
that or I'll note it and in due course
we'll we'll come to you obviously you
don't necessarily get called it
straightaway sir but we will know Chris
we are not taking over muting of Mike so
if you could use your mic so then I knew
when you when you're going going to
speak please avoid any temptations to
interrupt anyone indicate that you wish
to speak and then I'll come to you in
due course just as in any other meeting
you need to be here for the full
duration of an item that's been
discussed if if you're going to if
you're remembering I'm going to vote so
please avoid any temptations to wonder
off that because you're in more familiar
surroundings we are being recorded
we are being live-streamed we will check
and confirm that before we start and
just around eight o'clock with or just
in advance of eight o'clock we will stop
and take an adjournment so that said I
think we need to move on to the agenda
and item one emergency evacuation
announcement I think you can all in your
own domestic environments work out what
you need to do but if you do need to
leave please in it please let us know so
item one is apologies for
since I've got all members in Ando
counselor
Lucas Gill has had a problem substitute
there I'll go through substitute members
first so right as of now we have
counselor Gooding who is substituting
for counselor Lucas Gill and item three
it turns wrong non-members attending
I've got counts for mr. hoi cancel mrs.
Howe counselor mrs. Mason counts a step
toe counselor new for counselor er no
counts for sparing are there any of the
members that are not attending right
counselor mrs. nice and you've indicated
already ever missed you now I just can't
get the thumb down okay item four
minutes of the meeting held on the 13th
of February 2020 can you please on a
clearer show of hands indicate if you're
happy for me to sign those as a correct
and accurate record of that meeting okay
thank you very much for that item 5 is
declarations of interest right I'm going
to start with picking on goomer interest
item 9 on board counsel if that's our
item
scanning my screen
that's all I'm seeing at this moment in
time obviously if there's something that
crops up during the course of the
meeting then then please indicate okay
that means that we can move on to item 6
which is land to the north land north of
London Road south of roar roar at Lane
and west of roar of Industrial Estate
Rayleigh Katie Rogers is going to
present to us on this one
you will lose you will lose in case
you're not familiar you'll lose your
screen and you'll start to see plans ok
Katie if you would like to please thank
you
members on the screen you should see the
location plan this application relates
to part of the wider site the whole edge
blue on the screen was granted outline
planning permission for residential and
other development in 2016
phase 1 which is to the north just where
the cursor is here has been granted
reserved matters consent and development
is underway this application relates to
the area outlined led to the south of
phase 1 the western boundary of the
application site would run adjacent to
the spine road which will run through
the wider site from Roth Lane to the
north to the London Road to the south
on screen now is the outline consent
parameter plan that was approved the
outline consent established the areas of
the site that could be residential II
developed these are shown in the beige
color this application relates to this
central part here or reserved matters
namely layout scale appearance
landscaping and access are for
determination in this application all
other matters such as for instance
relate to drainage in ecology have been
dealt with at the outline stage there
are a number of planning conditions
relating to these on the outline consent
and these matters therefore cannot be
revisited here members this is the
layout plan of the proposed 120
dwellings dwellings wood front the
highway along the spine Road indicated
by the cursor here and there would also
front roads within the site a central
green space would be provided which
would be naught point to Hecht as an
area this would accord with the
requirement for such on the outline
planning consent and this would link to
the open space in phase one to the north
two points of access are proposed off
the spine road one here which will
provide Vic Euler access to the northern
part of the site and another point of
access to the southern boundary here
which would provide access to the
residential parcel to the South only
pedestrian access will be provided in
the green space in the central area all
dwellings would be provided with amenity
space as rear gardens and flats will be
provided with communal space the flats
on the proposal are here with the rear
amenity space here there's another block
of flats here again with the the amenity
space adjoining in addition there's a
flooded block here with amenity space to
the rear and one in this corner here to
the south car parking were provided on
plot or in parking courts or parallel to
the street such as some visitor spaces
along part of the central green space
for take you to the next plan this shows
the hard surfacing proposed and a number
of shared surface streets would feature
these are shown in the darker pink color
on the plan these will be surfaced in a
red tarmac to clearly denote areas where
there would be no separate pedestrian
footway private drives will be blocked
paved
the next plan shows you an indication of
the scale of the buildings proposed so
in terms of scale buildings would be
largely two-story with a handful of 2.5
story to the northern area here and then
three-story fluttered block to the
eastern boundary here
so some street scenes have be provided
and street scene a a which is on the top
of the screen and is indicated by the
cursor here on the layout plan shows the
dwellings which would front the spine
road in the northern part of the site
the first four dwellings indicated by
the cursor here would be two point five
storey with the remainder down to
two-story Section B B here again is an
elevation section that would front the
highway along here so these would face
the spine road and all be two-story in
height the central green space would
fall between the two vendor dwellings
and you will note that both elevations
to these dwellings would be fenestrated
this will provide overlooking of the
green space important to ensure that the
public space feels safe you'll note the
slight gradient to the section AAA and
that reflects the fact that the site is
not flat this more pronounced gradient
on the site is clearly seen in Section
EE and this is a section apologies this
is a section through looking north on
the central green space here you will
note that a variety of finishing
materials are proposed red and buff
brick as well as render and boarding the
dwellings would have traditional form
and appearance with pitch grooves and
symmetrical fenestration several
illustrations have been provided this
one shows a view across a section of the
central green space landscaping details
have been provided which are
comprehensive and show planting of a
significant number of trees in the
central green space and across the
widest sides the last visual shows you
the three-story flatted block proposed
and although more significant in height
and massing these would have an outlook
onto the adjacent green space and be of
a scale and appearance of appropriate to
this part of the site members all
aspects of the reserved matters are
considered acceptable and the
recommendation is therefore one of
approval subject to the stated
conditions including an amend
to condition to the condition listing
the approved plans to remove reference
to the design and access statement
planning statement and foul and surface
water technical note as these do not
need to be listed as a proof plans thank
you we've got a speaker on this one
although all of our speakers tonight are
submitted in the form of written
statements and Sonny Worthington is
going to read out this one which is
[Music]
thank you for the opportunity to speak
at this committee I'm Terry Tedder and
I'm the regional managing director for
burns or homes before I start I would
like to congratulate the council for its
efforts in ensuring that council
services can continue to operate at this
extraordinary time your office's have
shown phenomenal resilience and
adaptability in recent weeks and I would
like to extend my thanks for all that
they and you do I would also like to
reassure you about the plans that we
have in place to ensure that housing can
continue to be delivered you'll all be
aware that housing construction has
paused to respect the lock down
restrictions that are in place more
homes has been working with a wider
industry to identify ways in which
construction can resume safely and
housing delivery can commence I am
pleased to advise that floor Holmes has
put into faith robust and safe working
arrangements to allow construction of it
sites to resume this month your approval
of our scheme tonight would mean that we
will be able to commence development in
the coming months as planned and to
ensure that this important part of your
housing supply comes forward as soon as
possible
while providing jobs locally and
stimulating the economy tonight you're
being asked to approve the details
vast scheme it's worldly park you've
already approved the outline permission
for housing at this site and you will no
doubt to see that countryside has
started to build some of the homes
committed we have acquired a parcel of
land within the wider will be part right
and our application relates to that
parcel it is worth remembering that our
parcel is not being developed in
isolation the wider watery park
development delivers the road network
infrastructure and large areas of open
space and play facilities that surround
all of the past roots of development
leaving just the details of the housing
areas to be considered it is those
details as to before you tonight so the
past or that small homes will deliver
your office's report provides a thorough
and detailed description of the proposal
and explains that it is consistent with
the terms of both the outline Planning
Commission and your development plan
given the detail in the report
I intend to simply highlight the key
aspects of the proposal the proposal
provides 120 homes at a density that is
consistent with the density problem that
was approved as part of the outlines
mission it does not seek to increase the
density beyond that which you have
already considered to be reasonable
within this parcel these 120 homes
include 35% affordable housing which
equates to 42 new homes the entire
scheme includes the mix of 1 2 3 and 4
bed homes which has been discussed and
agreed with your offices as contributing
towards the housing needs of your
district the design of the scheme has
evolved through detailed discussions
with officers and advisors at ethics
police service plate services resulting
in the unequivocal support of the design
officer at paragraph 4.2 to be offered
this report the design of the scheme was
a matter that was reserved until this
application came along it has never been
a
by this council and so now is the first
time that you're being asked to consider
this which you can now do safe and the
knowledge that your statutory consul to
has provided his clear support for the
design throughout the design process we
have made sure that the scheme complies
with all relevant standards as a result
our scheme fully meets and in places
exceeds the party standards the
standards the separation distances
garden size requirements and the
national space standards we have also
redesigned elements and required
additional land with countryside
to ensure that the issues raised by the
highway authority can be addressed in
full as conserved at paragraph four
point three of the offices report
members you have before you a scheme
that is without objection and that your
officer has confirmed complies for both
the outline permission and your relevant
developments and policies I can confirm
that there are not any barriers that
prevent prevent us from delivering this
site as soon as you agree these details
I therefore respectfully request that
you agree with your office's
recommendation and approve this thing
tonight thank you if there are any
members that wish to say anything on
this one thank you Thank You mr.
chairman
[Music]
I've read this I'm having difficulty
because I've only got an electronic copy
but so forgive me if I can't refer to
the correct term paragraphs but with all
these types of applications the devil is
in the detail and overall it seems
predominantly a very good scheme however
there are areas of concern where those
concerns ease and you're not be
surprised to hear me say
this is the allocation of affordable
housing we have a clear policy that
pepper potting the fact that clear
policy is usually ignored doesn't
relieve it from being our policy it
shouldn't be aspirational it should be
achievable the design and layout is not
pepper potting its clustered and there
is a fundamental difference there is a
site that I'm quite familiar with down
in Rockford out I won't give the name of
the site and the difficulty with that
happens when you have this clustering of
is you get at them enough situation so
from perhaps a building perspective and
I can understand it from the applicants
perspective for selling it's fine but we
should be building homes for our
residents so that they can build a
community within that area rather than
there enough situation the other concern
I have with affordable housing is the
normal 35% should in my view be 35
percent of the four bedrooms 35 percent
of the three bedrooms but no what we
have here is a very clear discrimination
where the affordable housing is purely
all the one bed apartments all the to
bed apartments and I believe some of the
stupid houses I understand that this is
agreed with our housing and allocations
officer but I don't believe it
represents a true 35% and I do think we
should we also have residents that need
larger property but I don't think we've
got one for bed so that the larger
proportion to my mind is distortion of
this are we saying that no private
person wants to buy one-bedroom flats
and I also find the three-story block
rather an acceptable but that is a minor
point of us buyers over that the other
point that I'd like to point out they
candor stated that also to submit in the
officer's report not see if I can find
it it states that for the flats occurs
the affordable housing yeah I am going
to the point I'm just trying to find it
it's rather difficult in this forum for
the flats the amenity space
it says should have a minimum of 50
meters squared and miniskirt the
apartment block would not have balconies
the only private patio areas however the
block would be served by a grassy area
to the front aspect and 72 metres square
and rear and flank western ministry
spank amounting to 1.5 one totally some
two to three whilst this would not be 25
square meters per flats in this case the
amount of this amenity space is
considered acceptable given the
significant amount of open public green
space and I'm quoting here why do we
have a policy and then say that it's
acceptable when we don't meet that
policy I'll just leave that there I'll
leave it to the committee to decide but
I must admit though those are two
concerns that I think should be
addressed even if they're in conditions
thank you three minutes to 8 now so I
think it's a convenience to adjourn the
meeting I think if we adjourn now until
five past 8:00
please I think it would be sensible if
you didn't break your connections
just put your microphones on you maybe a
division are and do what you need to do
but five per state if you wouldn't mind
being back the restart
thank you
you
you
councillor Merrick you finally finally
all joined with us properly you know you
were really struggling when you yes I my
computer just crashed I I had a great
deal of difficulty getting back in the
end I had to reboot my iPad and
eventually got back to you so I shan't
be voting on this particular okay okay I
think I should I just just sit quietly
and listen to the rest of it thanks yeah
hopefully it won't happen again but I
gave him my fingers fast
you
I think it would also be appropriate
that I don't vote on the next item
either because they're inextricably
connected I think when you agree then I
try to be a wholly independent before I
wouldn't worry about that one and you
know you're okay with it all right
that's fine
right um looks like everyone is back now
it's five bus resumed the meeting then
so just as a reminder thank you for for
that which is hopefully appreciated by
those is intended for short days so when
I did six learn to the north land to the
north of London Road Raley
we've had our non-members speaking so
now this is for members we're looking on
the motion for approval which is printed
on six point one and eight points are
there any members that wish to
contribute here so counselor this is
sure Thank You chair looks fine but I've
got concern with the it's not gonna me
look it's not completely out of place
with what countries are already doing so
we'll have to the states completely
different they won't blend into street
scene thank you okay it's already been
said by Kessler Mason emulation to the
clustering and quite frankly not large
enough amenity space but he said that
there are several other items which I
would like to question the officer if
that's possible page six
10 on the on the documentation point 3 1
4 is this item still in appeal if she
could answer that one and then we go on
to item 3 point 4 2 disabled parking
there isn't sufficient I don't think
there is sufficient disabled parking and
that includes point three four four and
three four five where we do not have any
parking for mobiles and there are
meetings carriages not cars but
carriages where they is if we're going
to have disabled parking we need it for
their mobile facilities a lot of
disabled people may have carriages and
there is nothing on the site there for
them and also the 3.8 three and this
amount to the surface water that will
accumulate on the footpaths and in the
rooms it is said in the documentation
that is put the water you gathered
underneath of the footpaths but then
where does it go from there I don't see
any illustration as to where that water
that surface water goes and getting back
to the first thing that I mentioned for
housing needs is that it's not always a
one bed or a two bed that we should
accommodate it's also three baits and
maybe one or two more four bits so I
don't think that this is accommodating
enough on the site Thank You chairman
could I have an answer to those
questions please
yeah yes we'll come out to that right I
don't know what the members indicating
so I'm going to ask Casey to come back
on those those funky lighting style
pepper potting and to say bronze save
your facility Katie please
Thank You chairman and just bear with me
a second I'm just going to share my
screen again so members can see the
layout plan
you
hopefully members can see the layout
plan and so in respect of the first
question about affordable housing and
pepper potty so the affordable housing
properties are marked with a red dot so
you'll see that there's flats here
houses here flats here a house here in
the fluttered blocks here and where my
cursor is showing you to the eastern
boundary as well so between on this
eastern boundary between the affordable
there are a pair of semi-detached market
houses it is important to cheaper
potting the extent to that has to be
earned sort of worked out with the
developer as well in this case I think
if you look at the street scene so if
you take this elevations this street
scene here which would overlook the open
space to the north in phase one all of
these dwellings would face this space
here so they will have the front doors
onto this space and off that street if
you look say you could take around this
corner as well these are the affordable
you have affordable here but then you
have market housing going to the north
again on this little street in the
center you've got market housing then
leading to this dwelling here which
would be opposite of a market house as
well maybe to bear in mind is that this
development site is only part of this
central parcel so if you look at my
cursor here on this wider layout plan in
the bottom corner of your screen you'll
see that this southern part of this
parcel remains to be submitted for
reserve matters so we will have another
part of development here so maybe what
we need to be mindful of in future is
that we don't approve more affordable in
this particular location maybe but if
this adjoined more market housing here
maybe with affordable I'm going to the
the very southern extent that would sort
of even things up slightly again you're
gonna have and the spine road coming
through with another development parcel
here opposite and to the southwestern
corner which may well have affordable
fronting the street scene there it
that's something that we can consider
but taken in the round we think that
there is a enough of a mix in the area
of pepper potting for affordable I think
the next question
bear with me related to page six point
ten of the report and three point one
four and it referenced a previous
application at this site which was at
the outline stage it was Mitch din 2014
so it had a fourteen reference and
whether that's still at Appeal as far as
I understand it is so it is at Appeal
but I don't think there's any prospect
of the developer wanting the applicant
wanting to progress with that appeal
I have queried it over the last week or
so and asked for that to be updated that
appeal I think would likely be withdrawn
and because the 2016 outline consent and
then further reserve matters that relate
to that consent or being implemented at
the site and as we you know right now so
I don't think that appeal will progress
in relation to surface water footways
Andros in relation to this site the
issue of surface water drainage was
dealt with it the outline stage in great
detail if I take you back to the this
plan here this is the approved
parameters plan at the outline stage so
in the outline we considered that how
much of the site would be residential II
developed and the applicant was required
to submit a draft drip drainage strategy
and this included that they would use or
create attenuation basins so one to the
western boundary and then to more either
side of the Roth brook the whole site is
going to drain to these attenuation
basins and that includes all the water
that would land on any foot ways within
the site and roads
it'll all drain to these attenuation
basins and be held there and then drain
out of those attenuation basins into the
Roth brook at an agreed rate and that
agreed rate will achieve betterment in
relation to the rate that would have
happened for high intensity rainfall
events on this site but having said that
the surface water drainage is not a
matter for this reserved a masters
application the applicant if the
reserved matters is approved this
evening we'll need to submit a discharge
of condition application to for us to
agree detailed surface water drainage in
relation to this whole parcel and that
condition was imposed on the outlined
consent I'm just trying to go now to
that part of the plan so just bear with
me I'll just stop sharing this screen a
moment and just try to find the specific
part in the officer report that
councillor Stanley referred to in the
parking
[Music]
layout and parking paragraphs 3.40
on words if I just find the right
reference then I can share that on the
screen so paragraph three point four
four talks about the provision of
disabled bays so thirty visitor parking
spaces are provided which would include
three disabled parking bays and of the
provision of two hundred and eighteen
parking spaces this would include four
disable bays and four of the pros
properties on the site would be required
to be built to wheelchair accessibility
standards that's the only information I
have in relation to that at the moment
Oh in terms of sorry yes councillors
sure apologies I'm in relation to the
brickwork and the render if I take you
to if I just bring back up a street
scene plan and share that with you so
this is one of the streets T and so
you'll see there's a mix of render and
brickwork what I would say is that the
intention was at the outline stage that
there would be phases so sort of
character areas within the wider site
and with the number of dwellings to be
provided across the site as a whole and
that is about 500 dwellings you do want
some some variety in the areas so whilst
the materials proposed here would be
different to those proposed to the north
in that area the areas are sufficiently
big to warrant sort of different
materials and being used to give each
area a different character so it doesn't
just sort of all look a bit sort of
monotone across the site of 500
and we think these are appropriate at
the style of dwellings is quite
traditional so you've got pitch roof
small dormers and we think they would
look attractive and create a good
environment for people to live in okay
Chancellor Stanley is the only one that
I indicated to come back so I just had
countless families points and then we'll
progress this one Thank You Stanley
Thank You chairman there was there was
another couple of items which thank you
very much for elaborating on the parking
although there is there is wheelchair
accessibility in the property it doesn't
actually say mobility in the way of
getting out of the car or getting into
or moving into a mobile carriage not a
wheelchair says we know most disabled
people do have these mobile carriages
the other thing I wanted to raise was
who is attending to the corridor the
green corridor who is attending to there
as to looking after it cut in the grass
and so on and also the Forgotten ones
container
yeah just just who is attending to the
to the to the grounds my album oh yes
that's right the other question is could
you direct the officer direct a
assessment to the gardens to the
affordable homes I believe they're
undersized so she could she rectify that
query please is there anybody else wants
to make any fun I'm just conscious that
we we've got a fool estimation so we'll
just take take these answers and then
we'll progress okay okay if you wouldn't
mind
Thank You chairman in relation to the
green spaces the section the outline
consent was subject to a section 106
legal agreement which requires a
management management company
essentially to be in charge and maintain
public open spaces green spaces
throughout the site of which they're
going to be a number so this one
centrally positioned within this parcel
but also there are much bigger areas as
well to be maintained and so that would
be covered in that and the garden areas
to the affordable homes again if I just
I'm just going to bring up the lobe the
layout plan again I've been just zoom
into an area of that I'll share that
then
so on screen what you shall see is a
zoomed in section of the layout plan so
the affordable homes are with the red
dots so um here where the cursor is
these are flat so there's four flats
here and they have an amenity area to
the rear which is 100 square meters so
that does meet the requirement in terms
of 25 square meters of communal space
per flat there's then some houses that
have the required diminutive space to
the rear again here this is a flatter
block which has communal space that
meets requirements just to the north the
only affordable housing that does not
meet this sort of communal space per
flat 25 square meters would be this
these flatter blocks here but I think
taken as a whole the development does
achieve ample space in terms of open
green space for people to use throughout
and I think what we have to bear in mind
when when looking at this particular
flatty block is that the amount of open
space that's right essentially on the on
these people's doorsteps so they will
have this nice outlook onto this green
space within phase 1 and then which
extends to this screen castle and that
goes to the West here thank you
recommendation for approval which is
printed on page 6.1 there is an a
particular points that follow that plus
the things that have been withdrawn
they're not necessary can I ask that
those members in favor of the proposal
make a clear indication with their hand
Sonia can you just confirm that you've
seen everyone
okay those against okay I think that was
quite clear that item is carried thank
you very much for that one next is item
seven again land to the north of London
those rayleigh the construction of a
spine row on the same site but it's a
separate presentation so again katie is
going to take us through this one thank
you
Thank You chairman members should see on
screen
erm a location plan this application is
also at the sight of land north of
London Road and this plan shows the
whole site which is subject to the
outline consent for residential
development
I'm approved in 2016 to the right hand
side of the screen is Roth lane with
London Road running to the left-hand
side
the outline consent approved a spine
road running through the site from north
to south and several sections of this
road have already been granted reserved
matters approval this application is for
two further sections within the site by
sorry either side of the Roth brook just
pointed out by the cursor on the screen
there take to the layout plan this plan
is orientated Raworth lane to the top of
the screen and
the Roth Brook bisecting the site
east-west I just zoom in to the central
section so on the screen there seemed in
you'll see that proposed two sections of
the spy.road the northern and southern
sections would have a swale running
adjacent to the northern side of the
carriageway with an amenity grass verge
to the north foot waste would be
provided on either side of the
carriageway a bus stop will be provided
just where the cursor is here in the
southern section some changes to
existing land levels would be required
to achieve an appropriate gradient
involving raising and lowering the land
in places the northern section would
link to a section of the spine road that
has already been granted reserved
matters consent purchases ooh you can
see that here so the existing approval
extends down to here and this
application is proposing to Biggs you
know carry this spine road on the
section in the center is not subject to
this application there will be a bridge
over the brook that is still being
worked up and will be before members as
a reserve matters of application in due
course all reserve matters including the
layout access and landscaping or
accepted and the recommendation chairman
is therefore one of approval
okay or any of our non-members wanting
to speak on this one
[Music]
Thank You mr. chair and now I tried to
indicate before but I couldn't manage it
I've got to leave the meeting so
apologies Thank You members discussion
Chancellor Stanley you've indicated
Thank You chairman could I just ask
[Music]
identification as to who disagreed and
abstain we didn't get that on the last
count the with the bus stops are that
really is just before the bridge is that
the right place for a bus to be there
wouldn't be any overtaking or anything
like that and could lead to as that
could lead to a dangerous area I don't
think that the bus stops should be moved
further away from the bridge and I do
realize there are two junctions
according to the map that nevertheless I
do think that those bus stops should be
moved further away okay can I ask you
Caitie - yes determine um I would say
Essex County Council Highway Authority
have been consulted on the application
and have looked at where the bus stop
will be where the junction arrangements
will be and they're satisfied that the
proposal will comply with their
requirements they are going to adopt the
road in due course that's the intention
and therefore if they're satisfied with
them the positioning of the boss
stop the visibility's blaze etc we also
accept accept that the bus stop is
appropriately equated thank you quick
question for kite see with the we don't
mean you know about what's happening
with the bridge if it is quite a large
hump bridge could we relook at the bus
stop journey in the future thank you
should I come back
so I mean yes so what will need to
happen is that the the bridge design
will also need to be accepted by Essex
County Council if that then required the
bus stop to move in order for the County
Council to accept and adopt this road
that would be something that the
applicant may need to consider clearly
the applicant want would want this road
to be adopted by the Highway Authority
so if that needed to happen with a
revised revision to their consent in due
course and that may be the case but that
as it stands at the moment we don't know
that the bridge design would mean that
that bus stop is an appropriately
located
thank you I think every
South America good laughing indication
III just seek advice at the beginning of
before we take the vote before as Katie
started her presentation once again the
plan disappeared from my screen I could
still hear the presentation but I didn't
see the plan for a couple of minutes I
don't think it made any difference but I
would seek advice whether I should vote
on this occasion yeah unfortunately if
member hadn't seen the plan I would
argue that it's probably advisable not
to vote on that one because of see any
future suggestions so you agree with
that champ
okay Stanley you've indicated again
Thank You Jared just like to point out
that should that must not have to be
moved it would cost ten thousand pounds
to move it as was indicated when we was
to Essex County Council was to move the
bus stop from outside hand broke parade
shops to move it further down the road
to Hull Bridge Road yes making this this
decision the application is the
application and that's what me we must
determine for now I'm going going to go
to the road there now now we've had this
that clarity just for the sake of
clarity and in case anyone is listening
just audio wise and playing back we'll
do it we'll do a roll roll call vote so
if you can be hot on your unmute buttons
going through this I'm quite happy to go
to go it go through this so the motion
is for approval printed on page seven
five two of the report and I'll just go
through in order but I've got members so
I'll start with myself I am for
canceling mrs. Shaw for its with canal
for cancer SD or and Reeves or cancer
Gooding start shipping council Americas
that said he likes staying cancer mr.
Shaw for cancer Stanley for Council
Western hmm that's the Williams for
that's the Wilson for at the bottom oh
thank you very much that item is
approved a while I just pull up the next
item item 837 home brief road rail a
single-story flat roof addition I think
Casey will explain why this one normally
come to us but if you'd like to
presented that through stages thank you
Thank You chairman I'll just share the
screen members you should be able to see
the location plan for this item this is
an application that would usually be
delegated and not come before the
Development Committee however this is
required in this case as the applicant
is related to a council officer the site
is edged read on the plan on the screen
and has a deep front garden and smaller
garden to the rear take you to the block
plan the proposal is for a single-story
rare extension the members will note
from the site plan to the top here that
the proposed extension would be to a
depth in line with the extension to the
attached neighbor you can see the
elevations proposed on screen now a
window is also proposed to the side
elevation and the extension would have a
flat roof and feature a roof light no
neighbor objections have been received
and the proposal would not be readily
visible from the street scene it is
considered that the proposal would not
give rise to any harm and would comply
with adopted council policies the
recommendation is one of approval thank
you
thank you don't have any non members
wishing to speak on this one not one of
almost controversial applications and
anything but do any members wish to
speak on this one council America same
same problem again chairman once the
plan comes up I lose the the picture
from my screen and then it takes a
couple of minutes before I can get it
back again and I'm thinking this is
going to happen on every occasion so I
think if you agree it would be sensible
that I leave the meeting
altogether and and we try and get this
sorted out for future meetings that your
decision ultimately I do understand can
I just
yeah I'm same situation is the last item
I think chair and unfortunately if
members gonna have you know temple
technical difficulties and there's any
sort of suggestion that you know all the
information was available I think it's
gonna be and what yeah well obviously
where he wants to stay in a job is
obviously up to him so Mary do you
actually have copies of the plans all
right I had the need the report okay
saying in the report which I don't think
now one wasn't the same as what was on
the came on the screen of it when I
eventually got it back
all work well we'll understand that
there isn't really on some future
occasions remembers chances family
you've indicated thank you German there
they think I think 3.14 is Park II could
could allow so to go back to the plane
please once make your point issue as we
go that is there the parking reasons is
there tandem parking on site Casey would
you like to just describe the parking
arrangements lays
apologies chairman had a problem
unmuting but it's okay now if I share my
screen I'll just go to the block plan so
the block plan is on the screen here and
this is the long front garden and
there's a driveway to the front and and
that the proposed development to the
rear of the property does not affect the
existing parking arrangements on the
site it has parking that complies with
the council's parking standard that's
fine Thank You chairman okay members
where we'll go to the baryon on this one
it's on 8.1 they're the three points of
recommendation for approval but on the
mute buttons again please I start with
myself
that's a Smith for counselor mrs. Shaw
that's now lost him okay
Chancellor FD for cancer AIDS bidding
Justin Eric I can't make John counselor
counsel mr. Shaw for justice Stanley for
cancer Western the Williams improve
cancer Wilson
that's the Wilson win this year there or
cancel button or I'm back to cancer
canal or Thank You chair thank you very
much I can item nine four eight three
Ashington Road Ashington retrospective
application replace picket fence can I
just remind members before we do this
one the fact that this item is
retrospective is not a material planning
concern Thank You chairman Anza tween is
the location plan the site is at red and
has a boundary to both Ashington rose to
the east an Albert Road to the north but
just take you to the block plan the
proposal seeks retrospective planning
permission to retain an enclosing
boundary fence to the boundary along
Ashenden Road denoted by the yellow
highlighting on the plan on screen this
photo shows the fence that is the
subject of the application behind the
road sign the dark
fence along the Albert Road boundary
isn't it is historic and lawful and not
the subject of the application so the
application before you tonight solely
relates to this brighter colored fence
behind the Albert Road sign
this street image shows the site at a
time before the closed boarded fencing
was erected along the boundary frontage
with a stencil with Ashington Road
members the site is within a built-up
residential area with similar corner
plot properties dotted the length of
Ashenden Road most properties along
Ashenden Road have Vick Euler access
from the highway and and her front
gardens that feature parking and soft
landscaping
most front boundaries adjacent Ashenden
mode are lower in height providing a
degree of spaciousness about the street
scene which helps to create a character
thus to the locality which is visually
attractive and an environment attractive
to pedestrians using the foot way along
this busy street significant length of
the of heart of higher clothes boarded
fencing can appear visually unattractive
especially when on a boundary very
prominent in the public realm
if replicated the cumulative resulting
impact to the attractiveness of the
street scene would be very significant
in this prominent location that proposed
higher closed boarded fence is
considered inappropriate and harmful to
visual amenity in the street scene and
the recommendation chairman is therefore
one of refusal thank you we have a
speaker statement on this miss Sean
Barlow who is the applicant and again
Sonia is going to read this one out
I'm writing today to state my reasons
for swapping a picket fence with a
timber fence in the garden of 483
Ashington Road firstly I'd like to add
that I never knew you needed planning
permission to erect a fence on your
property hence the reason this has
already been done but below are all the
reasons for doing so main reason is the
security for my children and dog this
property fronts the Ashington road which
is one of the busiest roads in the area
my dog actually got out through the
picket fence prior to putting the fencer
but luckily managed to get her before
she headed into the road our next-door
neighbor has an adjoining fence that is
1.5 metres high the cross the road is a
public house where we had two drunk guys
one evening talking to my children
frightening them and leaving them
running in crying adding to the perb we
have also witnessed people jump the
fence and kick the kids footballs in the
garden there are eight other properties
on a shegaon road with the same style
fencing at roughly the same height
certainly above a meter high I gathered
this is OK to do there are no sight
issues with regard to leaving Albert
Road as proven by the Highways Agency
the fence is a continuation of an
existing fence that also rejoined for
highway Albert Road that has been there
for many years the existing fence with
the picket style the highways grass
areas unfortunately not cut on a regular
basis therefore the weeds and lengthy
grass progressing into my garden are a
constant issue there is a local man and
shown the name who is known to have
mental health problems that has been
witnessed leaning over the picket fence
picking up items in my property all of
the above reasons why we changed style
of fences and have been complimented on
many occasions from residents and also
the businesses officer
or any of our non-members that the
wishing to speak on this one okay thank
you
no discounts the West German Katie the
old fence that was there has some I
noticed when you shows the pitch before
the picket fence did they and the picket
fence was that going against the the
Elliot the old fence that there the old
fence that is there at the moment I was
the picket fence all around the hole of
the property and the old fence was put
there later on forget my meaning let's
go to the second question sorry okay
second question Maggie had any any
complaints from neighbors because of the
because that side of the fence as well
please thank you yes I agree with the
officer in their recommendations he's
not in character with the surrounding
area even though then the road further
might be just 1.5 meters it's still not
in character with where the rest of the
street scene so we I totally agree with
the officer thank you okay Chet can ask
Katie what the standard is that he's
there because it's a little confusing to
us to make a decision on this when you
look at the faint fence next door with
1.5 seems very little difference if this
applicant actually then reapplied to 1.5
high with that then conform to standard
or does it need to be lower I'm a little
bit confused because we aren't you
haven't actually explained to us what
the standard should be thank you
I live in the area and pass this
property probably four or five times a
week I hadn't even noticed the fence had
gone up it is an angle it doesn't
actually go straight in line with the
highway it reduces back into Alba Road
and is not really noticeable and the 1.5
meter fence isn't down the road it's
next door so I would have no hesitation
in recommending this for approval thank
you I've got same as councillor Williams
actually I Drive past there quite often
and until this plane application came up
I didn't even know his defense had
changed and I think you know I'd have no
objection to this at all so just share
the image again the first question
related to where the picket fence went
up to so it went across the whole of the
front boundary adjoining into the close
wooded fence that went along the Albert
Road frontage the second question
related to any complaints from neighbors
I all I can say on that matter is that
it's a retrospective application that I
understand has come from an enforcement
inquiry then I think councilor either
asked about Ammar standard so what the
applicant householder could do without
needing to apply to the local authority
for planning permission is put a
boundary treatment wall fence up to the
one meter in height from ground level
anything above that would require
planning permission and I think the
concern here is in this it's a very
public setting it's a busy street with
pedestrians as well if it were
replicated setting a precedent that
might have cumulative negative impact
and it's quite a long length that we're
talking about
the short length that the neighboring
property has their fence up to but it's
more significant than that I hope that
answers the question
indeed the the boundary does not have to
be marked by a fence it could be planted
in which case obviously if it were hedge
Green perhaps potentially less visually
prominent could go clearly beyond a
meter in height what a need planning
permission I think this is quite just a
quick question well look at the picket
fence is that their back garden or their
front garden is there a front garden
application okay okay can we just have a
little look at the young the visual with
the fence in phase with the high fence
thank you Thank You chairman okay
members this is a slightly tricky one in
my my opinion we have our policies our
professional judgment by our officers is
that this doesn't comply and they're
recommending for refusal it might not
make a difference but equally a house in
the woods in the middle of the Greenbelt
might not make any difference if no one
can see it's a no longer complain we do
have to be conscious in a public in a
prominent location of the ongoing
precedent that this might create
technically everybody that lives in the
Ashenden own if this what in the edge of
the road if this one were approved could
put up a a six-foot fence and I'm very
reluctant to see this one go through
there are other boundary treatments
available a meter is available in war
then greenery above that there there are
options so my inclination is to support
our policy and support our officers even
though the demonstrable harm and the
actual use that the applicant is getting
from it so I think we'll go to the votes
now so again just for the sake of
clarity the recommendation is for
refusal that your relative should be
very positively this is B for refusal at
this moment of time so I'll start with
myself
counsel Smith for counselor mrs. Shah
inst
[Music]
that's correct
now moving on the first one item 10 one
is 23 Harrogate Road properly
demolishing existing residential
dwelling who construct a four-bed
dwelling house JD Rogers is going to
that so members will see on the screen
the location plan the application site
is edge red with a frontage on to
Harrogate Road a detached bungalow had
until recently occupied this occupied
the plot with a frontage approximately
in Lion with the neighboring property is
to the north and the south
just going to zoom in to a section of
this plan so members would be able to
see on the screen in the on the
right-hand side M the proposed site plan
the proposal seeks to construct a
detached two-story house in place of the
bungalow the front elevation would be
approximately again in line with the
dwellings to the north and south shown
by the cursor on the screen here parking
a soft landscaping will be provided to
the frontage to the rear a patio which
is this area here when shown by the
cursor would be provided and to the rare
if that's the garden laid two lon
the rear elevation of the property would
be approximately again in line with the
neighboring properties to the north and
south with a single-story part of the
proposed dwelling extending projecting
slightly deeper than the two-story rare
wall that's shown by the cursor here
there's the two-story and then the
single-story Park gets slightly further
this site plan has annotated on it lines
denoting a 45 degree angle from the rear
corners of the neighboring dwellings so
that's here with the cursor here and
here with the cursor here this
demonstrates that the council's policy
that a 45 degree angle not be breached a
two-story level would be met by the
proposed dwelling just zoom out of this
plan
and you can see the proposed elevations
to the top of the screen show a
traditional building format hit throughs
on all sides and symmetrically
positioned fenestration windows at first
floor level in the side elevation would
be obscure glazed you can see the street
scene proposed to the bottom of the
screen might just I'll just zoom in or
not slightly so it's clear before you
sew the top street scene shows as
existing and the bottom shows the
proposed two-story house shows the
dwelling sits in it happy this shows how
the dwelling sits in its immediate
context the neighbors to the north and
south are not two-story houses although
one is a chalet and the overall height
of the proposed dwelling would exceed
that of the neighbors
however the roof being pitched on all
sides reduces the massing of the
dwelling and provides for a greater
degree of spaciousness about the
property and between them and between
the neighboring dwellings the council's
policy requirement that a meter
separation be achieved to both side
boundaries would be met I'll take you to
a street view so you can now see a
street view this is not looking at the
application site this is further down
Harrogate Road and this is looking at
number 43 in the center of your screen
the dwellings on either side of this are
also a chalet in a bungalow and
demonstrates that the existing character
of the street scene is mixed and the
proposal would not appear out of place
to the detriment of visual amenity in
this location I take you back to the
location plan so this is number 43 here
so the image that was just on screen
that shows an existing two-story house
is this property that's I'm pointing out
with the cursor here and you've got a
chalet and a bungalow to either side of
that
again those dwellings are approximately
in line to the front yet they're
somewhat staggered to the rear this
house projects slightly further than one
but not quite as far as another concerns
have been raised by neighboring
occupiers pertick
with regard to concern that the proposal
would cause overshadowing and loss of
light in the determination of a planning
application whether a proposal is
acceptable with regard to impact on
amenity of neighboring dwellings is a
material consideration in this case
however the dwelling would not project
excessively beyond the rear wall of the
neighboring dwellings the siting would
not breach the council's 45 degree
policy and she's therefore considered
that the proposal would not cause all
unreasonable harm by way of
overshadowing to either neighboring
dwelling in this mixed street scene the
proposal for a detached two-story house
would not be out of character the
recommendation chairman is one of
approval speaker statements for this the
first one is for mr. O'Brien as an
object chair and again Sonny Worthington
is going to move this one out
dear chairman dear chairman and members
of the development committee when my
wife and I bought the property next door
to 23 Harrogate Road a little over five
and a half years ago we were attracted
by the lovely light airy position is
enjoyed however all of that is now in
jeopardy if this application goes
through in its current form consequently
we would object to the application
before you on three grounds namely that
the total scale and mass of the proposed
building represents a significant over
development of the site secondly that it
is out of keeping with a street scene
thirdly that it would be detrimental to
our amenity by way of the significant
impact on the light recede in our home
caused by its sheer overall mass and
overbearing firstly when the previous
owner of number 23 passed away
approximately 16 months ago we were not
naive enough to think that someone
wouldn't look to buy the property and
seek to extend it however this proposal
is a significantly larger development
than we've ever imagined it is almost
three times the size of the previous
building and beside all that would face
this would be about 2.7 5 times the size
of the previous one and it would be
around 2.6 meters closer that is 8 and a
half feet its sheer size will dwarf most
of the properties in Harrogate Road as
well as limited those behind it
certainly the residents of 32 lamington
Road did object to the proposal on the
grounds of adverse effect on their
residential amenity by reason of
overlooking and loss of privacy a
consideration and account for policy DM
1 9 the objection has not been included
in the offices report because it was
received by watcher district council
after the due date for submissions I
understand this is because the residents
concerned did not receive a consultation
letter however it does serve to
illustrate their concern at the likely
impact the sheer size and must this
development will have on them and other
neighbors in Lebanon Road further
contrary to paragraph 13 of the planning
of offices report the scale felt and
height of the proposed building is not
comparable to other properties in the
vicinity that is unless the definition
of vicinity being used includes roads
within a quarter-mile radius policy DM
to six of the councillors management
plans states that development must be a
suitable density for the locality this
supplication before you appears to be of
greater density than any other existing
property in Harrogate Road secondly as
stated in paragraph one of the planning
officers report the area surrounding the
site missed residential in character and
the street scene principally presents a
mix of bungalows and shallow Benga loads
of similar form and appearance the
current design style of the application
and its pure scale cannot be considered
commensurate with the vast majority of
properties in the road and there so
would be in contravention of policy H
one of the core strategy policies dm1
and cm3 of the development management
plan SPD to housing design and the NPP s
policy H one of the council called
strategy states that in order to protect
the character of existing settlements
the council will resist the
intensification of smaller sites within
residential areas although limited
infill will be considered acceptable it
will have to relate well to the street
pattern density and character of the
locality in addition policy dm3 of the
development management plan also
requires consideration of whether the
number and types of dwellings are
appropriate to the locality it is our
view that this development
sailes these tests thirdly our home lies
in a unique position in relation to 23
Harrogate Road in that it has an
entrance door and key habitable rooms to
the side of the property that face
almost exactly due south
consequently we receive the bulk of our
primary direct sunlight for a
significant number of hours each day
from this side equally the predominant
secondary light source into other parts
of our home comes from this side as
already stated the sheer enormity of the
proposed development combined with its
closeness eight and a half feet closer
will have a significant overshadowing
effect and a significant detrimental
impact on the light personating into our
home the planning officer states in
paragraph 22 that any overshadowing
would only occur during the day and only
for a small proportion of daylight hours
any additional loss of light from the
proposal those who endure first have
already lost from the existing building
is likely to be minimal given the
orientation and distance between the two
buildings we would refute this statement
not least because the overshadowing of
the news of the laude book demolish
property lasted well into the evening at
this time of year so a development of
largest-scale and maths will increase
the overshadowing considerably we have
asked the applicants representatives on
more than one occasion to have a proper
Independence Day light and sunlight
survey carried out in order to ascertain
the consequential impact of the
development to date they have declined
to do so for the record the loss of
light to 21 Harrogate Road is likely to
be minimal at the entrance door to this
property faces north with the
consequence of its primary light source
is received from the front and rear of
the property we tried to discuss the way
forward with the applicants
representative but it quickly became
evident that they weren't prepared to
deviate in any noteworthy way from their
current position
whilst
the applicant is adhering to the Essex
party standards document 2010 this same
document states it is now recognized
that providing a reduced number of
parking spaces is a travel origin does
not discourage people from owning a car
therefore parking standards for origins
should be used as the minimum standard
this application is for a four bedroom
property thereby providing the potential
for more than two or three car owners
residents of Harrogate Road already
suffered from high levels of commuter
parking through when parking etc and are
being supported strongly by county
district and parish councillors in their
efforts to introduce parking
restrictions the risk of additional cars
being parked on the road is high from
the proposal and therefore is of concern
to residents as demonstrated by those
raised by the resident of 16 Harrogate
Road the comments above are the ones we
have to make in a formal way the reality
is that there is an emotional side to
this issue also for us
these are the prospect of being faced by
an enormous brick wall each and every
time we leave our home the oppression of
being severely overshadows all the time
we wish that you could have seen the
situation firsthand because then you
could have gained a full understanding
at the perspective change in our
situation however as the old building is
now being demolished that is no longer
possible
so picture if you will a two-bedroom
bungalow becoming a structure mass
almost three times as big and over two
and a half times the height the
structure is closer by almost nine feet
try to visualize the big brick wall that
would be safe every time the door is
opened
then imagine if you would that it is
your door to your home finally we do
appreciate the time you have taken to
listen to and consider our submission
and are sure that you will recognize how
important it was for us to be able to
place our objections before you tonight
thank you we have a second short of
submission for Sonia to read again from
mr. Colin Donovan who is the applicant
yes
good evening mr. chairman and members of
the development committee may I take
this opportunity to pass on my best
wishes to everyone in these difficult
times
my name is Colin Donovan to ddw
developments and I wanted to outline
some important points regarding our
application at 23 Harrogate Road plans
are submitted on the 16th of October
2019 for a detached Chalet to replace
the existing detached bungalow our case
officer advised amending the plans to a
detached house as she had concerns
relating to the scale and form of the
proposal the changes included reducing
the depth of the proposed will at first
floor and altering the roof form we
therefore followed this advice and
resubmitted the plans for a four bedroom
detached dwelling on the 20th of
December 2019 one of the reasons our
application has been submitted for
referral this evening is that our
proposal would constitute over
development however point 11 in
tonight's agenda states that the
proposed dwelling by virtue of exciting
would not be harmful to the character
and appearance of the street indeed
point 13 continues to add the scale bulk
and height of the proposed dwelling is
comparable to that of ever dwellings
that have been Harrogate Road Harrogate
Road Wood has a mixture of semi-detached
Venga loads and chalets in addition to
detached firm below the chalets and
houses another reason stated is the
possibility of a loss of light to an
adjoining property which we have been
advised is not a material planning
consideration our architect has advised
that the overshadowing on the side
windows would be very minimal within the
winter months
a non-existent within the summer months
in conclusion we have changed our
application in response to the officers
concerns relating to the scale and form
of the proposal and feel we have now met
the criteria Rochford District Council
planning policy thank you for your time
this evening thank you do any of our
non-members wish to speak on this one
Chancellor mr. Hawley please sorry we're
not getting volume from you right now
I know Harrogate Road where this
building is there is a I'm gonna use
Diane's microphone
sorry I'm now dying sorry about this the
microphones are blowing up the unknown
Harrogate Road quite well and there is a
an issue around this this this is
totally out of keeping with the
character of the street where he is I'm
sure counselor mrs. Weston will bring
this up as well around number 23 there
are bungalows or chalets of nowhere near
the height of this proposed property I
think there are some detached houses but
there are not further up they're not
opposite it and they're not next door to
it they're not they can't be within ten
houses or even and I think that the
height and bulk of this is totally out
of character with the part of the street
scene that this will occupy that's
really the comments I was making
thank you did Cass the missus high and
also indication wish to wish to say
something
if you could just onion mrs. Hong place
no just confirm if you did wish to speak
mrs. high-camp the high thank you mrs.
hi can I have another non-members wish
to speak okay we'll move on counts the
Western you referred this one so would
you like to speak please yes I did
chairman thank you very much and I'm
concerned because Co builders are we
knocked down the bungalow and I didn't
realize they could do that until it's
Ozzy come to the Development Committee
I'm Katie and then of whether you have
have you got a street view of the number
25 and the anger over it was before he
got knocked down at all if you bear with
me I might gather up I do agree because
this the the property that we're talking
about is is overdevelopment much much
bigger than the house you showed us just
now and the height of it I know you're
saying about roots is um it goes up into
a point it says it's again way over over
the faster to bungalows by the side of
it and their bungalows right near it and
it's and also it's more it's coming onto
a beans going around Harrogate Road so I
do feel that this is this this two
bedroom two is detached and four-bedroom
property is way over above the scale of
what it should be and not under mental
to the to the street scene as well I
want you to see whether you could find
me a street scene of 25 and the bungalow
that was then just to give you an idea
there's that number 20 is that 25 with
it with the other car in those 23 with
the other communist so the the other one
the other bungalow is the one they've
knocked down ready then apologists for
the might of amusement yes so you can
see the site like that okay so that one
glows the one in the middle where the
bungalow is the one with the red car in
that's the bundle has been knocked down
now to the the the height of the new
house is gonna be way above those two
those two Punggol owns the detached one
and the other bungalow way over and
above could you can see the size of that
small bungalow and you're now gonna have
an astronomical huger og tax property I
mean I want to put this up for refusal
of the over over development of the of
the end the property itself I know I'm
not too sure about the light the light
side but I've done and that's the only
thing I can think of the size of the new
property being built then it's question
I had salt got answered in their first
statement which was about the where
they've had a loss of lights consultant
going to it on their behalf and ours and
you sort of answered the question when
there's no it's not a sacrifice to
decide about the loss of light you've
done already done the 45-degree angle
thing but I was just wondering why and
that's the reason why they haven't
replied to this I suspect so I was
wondering if there was a reply and if
they if there was gonna be one verse it
sort of doesn't quite matter now
thank you that's a Stanley
Thank You German I'd like to point out
to the committee that in 2017 when we
had a inspector look at the one of the
officers comments on the 45 degree it
was agreed that the center of the window
and not the edge of the window would be
adopted and that should that should have
held the officer in determining the 45
degree however I do think that DM one
number five number nine number 10 and
number 11 if you want me to read those
out I can do and also DM 3 number 10 and
DM 31 and with these policies that we
have made I'd like to put a motion
forward that we reject this on these
policies thank you
Thank You counselor next wave Thank You
chair just one of the things in the
presentation not be concerned about
these from what I understand in
conversations I had in looking at the
application beforehand the developer did
actually originally put forward a
smaller development and our planning
officers advised that they could
actually go bigger chance the Western
you refers this and indicated that you
were looking to move the refusal it's
big difficult to just take get a call
out for anyone willing to second Jim but
obviously in the discussion so far
counselors family was also indicated
that he'd look to move to refusal on
this one as you referred it first
counselor Western if I come back to you
if you'd like to just reiterate before
we go forward please I'd like to infuse
it only aspect of being over development
on that site and if counsel Stanley
would include a couple of his points as
well included in there and the refusal I
would be more than happy to do that
chairman for refusal okay we we need to
be very clear on our reasons refused of
the specific a big is it isn't
sufficient detail so I'll come to
counselor Stanley next and if cancer
standing you can indicate first of all
if you're willing to second and then
offer chance the western if you if it's
appropriate reasons Thank You Stanley
Thank You chairman I do think that we
need to refuse it not just on the bulk
of whatever you so
yes thank you
do you want the DM yeah if you could
offer some accounts of Western specifics
please okay the policy dn1 which is
which is number five number nine and
number ten and number 11 which indicates
it's efficient talking with policy DM
thirty Boyd overlooking and insurance
ensuring privacy and promoting visual
amenity number ten is a position
relationship with the existing and
thereby buildings in accordance with
policy da three number eleven is a scale
and full of appropriate to locality in
line with policy DM 3 thank you and here
I now need to refer back to offices
plays on those particular reasons okay
if you'd like to come back please thank
you I think there was a question from
councillor eaves regarding officers
discussing with the applicant potential
amendments to schemes all I can say in
relation to this application is that we
have the application before as an
officers do go back sometimes to
applicants agents in the course of an
application what we're seeking to make
sure is that schemes
comply with adopted council policy so
sometimes those changes can relate to
design sometimes size certainly we
wouldn't be suggesting amendments that
would cause a greater degree of harm or
not compliance with council policy the
scheme is the one that we have before us
tonight
and in relation to the reasons for
refusal I think we do we do need some
clarity I have concern particularly
about any reason for refusal relating to
insufficient parking and if I just share
on the screen and again I'm just going
to zoom in to the site plan so the
property will benefit from an integral
garage
sorry just so to the right-hand side of
your screen here you should see this
site layout plan so there's two parking
bays here and that meet the council's
required standard in addition to an
integral garage I would be very
concerned about any recommendation for a
reason for a fusing involving
insufficient parking the clarity counts
the Western are you happy to remove that
reason for insufficient parking based on
the officer recommendation sorry can you
hear me now yeah I don't think so be
honest for you because for a 4-bedroom
house that size it's gonna need more
than two two parking spaces that would
concern me with having more part more
cars parking on the road I have a gate
mode just say we did we just here's
really clearly some officers that we
have compliance with standards so
whether the house okay
yeah yeah um also I'm sorry I've just
zoomed into this and section of the
floor plan that shows the integral
garbage that's proposed in addition to
the two parking bays in front of it on
the driveway I'm just gonna zoom out of
this plan slightly so I think I've also
heard in in the discussion about a
reason for a fuse or relating to
ensuring privacy to neighboring
properties so this where my cursor is
now we're looking at the first floor
plan though there are windows proposed
inside elevation at first floor they'd
serve bathrooms and on Suites and
there's a condition imposed that would
require those windows to be obscure
glazed and fixed shots you know and so I
can't really think we can support a
reason for a few so that suggests that
this is going to cause an undue loss of
privacy to neighboring properties as a
result of overlooking if we if I just
then again point out on this and so my
cursor is on the right-hand side of the
screen now so those windows would be in
the first floor level here and then to
the southern boundary here and windows
at first floor level in a rear elevation
or just not an unusual thing in a
residential area such as this and we
wouldn't really be concerned with any
overlooking from the ground floor
windows so I am concerned about how we
can support a reason for refusal around
ensuring privacy and to neighboring
dwellings I'm noting that you're
indicating Castor's family but I'm just
welcome back to you just need to go to
the western proposing the Western can
you comment on whether you accept the
officer remark regarding
the privacy the side-ops you're on and
so on new place sorry
yes I'll have to accept that and I can't
accept what she's saying thank you can I
come in for a moment I'd like I'd like
the officer to finish their their
comment and then we'll go to the the
emotion that we're specifically talking
to well not to come in and ask questions
yeah the office is going to finish their
comment okay so I think if we we need to
sort of recommend that we flesh out a
reason for refusal it can't just simply
state about overdevelopment I think we
need to explore the harm that this
proposal would cause so I think there's
also been referenced to parts of dm1
policy that talk about relationship with
nearby buildings the scale and form
appropriate to the locality but I just
haven't heard that discussed in relation
to the reason for a fuse or sort of as a
whole and the issue of overdevelopment
all I would say on that point is that
yes the proposed dwelling would be
significantly larger and then the
existing dwelling on the site but was
there it's been demolished now that
bungalow was particularly modest on in
the street scene so perhaps the
difference is more stark but I think
what we have to consider is not what the
difference would be but we need to focus
on this street scene at the bottom of
the screen here so rather than compare
the two if you like it's about how this
would appear in the street scene if it
were built and there is a degree of
spaciousness between the properties it
is if it is of a width but it does
achieve a swampy to separation to each
side and the hip roof albeit high yes
the the eaves level where the two-story
such a part would be would be in line
with the drama
to the side of the chalet and the hip
truth just create a greater degree of
spaciousness these properties would be
in line so they wouldn't be this plot
this dwelling would not be cited further
forward more prominent and than these
two in terms of the front elevation
thank you the Western if you could
whether you want to stick with your
comment which are I think I interpreted
that the overall scale bone can mass of
the building would we get to mentor to
the visual amenity of the street yeah
that's what I'm saying I don't still
believe it it easy it's the the the post
really is is overbearing and it's not
not in keeping with the street scene and
especially next to see other other
properties as well chairman Westerners
as you indicated you wanted Thank You
chairman there was no mention about a
forty-five degree which was agreed with
the inspector a center of the window and
not the edge of the window as portrayed
but nevertheless the council do not like
or would not like do not like tandem
parking and there is a car in front of a
garage as well as using the garage as
another parking area because there is
tandem parking so there is one other
thing and the fact is that when it says
ensuring privacy and promoting visual
and amenity well it's not a very visual
amenity with a rather large blank wall
of bricks which we if I remember right
the rally itself we asked the occupants
of that particular building to make it
more amenable of the prop
feisty the brick wall that was facing
the property in that garden when it was
built and we had them do something about
it in the way of making it more of a
visual community rather than a one big
lump of bricks in other words so what
all I'm not I'm not totally satisfied
with this ensuring privacy from the
people in the house it's more from
people outside of the house that are
looking to the house and I think that
there is something which has already
been mentioned but I do support canceled
westerns overbearing and not in visual
correspondence with the surrounding area
Thank You Katie if you would just go
over your understanding of the reasons
for refusal is to make sure that
everyone's clear yes did you want me to
respond to anything that we've just
heard are you happy to meet you disco
okay okay so the reason for refusal I've
heard is that this concern that the
overall scale bulk and mass of the
proposed dwelling will be detrimental to
visual amenity in the streets in out of
character then I that also heard
overbearing I just would like to clarify
whether the concern is solely Malaysian
to the visual amenity in the street
scene and the impact on the character of
the locality rather than including any
concern about particular harmful impact
on residential amenity to either
neighbouring prophecy of Weston if you
could just confirm are you concerned
about the law that the visual amenity to
the neighbors or the visual amenity to
the street see
most of you honest with you chairman
obviously with the vigil amenity I'm
just that's clear like you're concerned
that this dwelling would be
inappropriate because of its mass its
high to scale up everything taken in the
round in this particular plot in this
street scene so the reason for refusal
is all about that and will relate that
back to the relevant positive policy DM
1 and the I think what I'm understanding
is that you accept and that the proposal
wouldn't specifically cause any harm by
way of overshadowing being overbearing
on the residential amenity of either
neighboring property it's more about how
it looks in the street scene yeah yeah
yeah yes okay okay William she just did
a quick indication before we thank you
chairman on the show this is relevant
I've just been looking on Google Maps
looking at this street I really don't
think this would interfere with the
street saying it's quite a mixed bag I
wouldn't have any problems with with
authorizing this thank you chair thank
you just in case of you voting on this
matter do so technical difficulties
during the offices original report I'll
be out staining from the vote it's a
very quick point chair thank you one of
the things that was difficult about this
particular application to consider is
the fact that you going from one extreme
to the other there's no doubt that the
previous building there was a
significant underdevelopment of the site
yeah okay the Builder is pushing it to
the extreme but I tend to agree with
councillor Williams we're in the street
scene I went down there earlier on and
the street scene is so mixed down there
I'm a little bit unsure as to whether
I'll appeal we'd actually win the the
argument
moment thank you
I got the good in you indicated yes so
chair the just can you clarify with the
park in there
I heard councillor Stanley mentioned
that it was tandem parking but from the
visuals that I saw it looked to me that
it was side by side parking judge just
now we're moving for a reason for
refusal and the parking hasn't been
mentioned as as a reason if this motion
for refusal isn't successful then we'll
come back to that right members we have
a motion for refusal but forward by
counts the Western and councillor
Stanley the officer is just been going
over the reasons so we'll go through the
members so you ready on your buttons
counselor MIT mrs. Shaw for or against
the refusal against the canal you've
said you ducked out on this one count
for everything for or against going to
refuse them oh thanks to the Gooding
I've stayed in cancer mr. Shaw the game
counts for Stanley four counts of
Western and counts the Williams against
the Wilson full count the wooden bench
and the South on against the refusal so
if I can just check with Sonya I've got
that three for the refusal and
seven against the refusal direct correct
so members that item for refusal has
been defeated so I now move to the movie
approval which is printed on ten point
one point one one it was nine points
there could I just ask before we go any
further on that if Katie could just ask
answer the question that councillor
gooding foot with regard to the parking
blaze
thank you just share my screen again
it's gonna scroll up to the layout plan
across
so members can see clearly I presumed in
a bit more to the layout plan that's
proposed and to the right-hand side of
your screen there are two parking spaces
either side of each other on the
driveway accessed by a drop curb that
we're on to Harrogate Road so you know
easy access to both of those off have a
good Road independent of each other and
then in addition there's a parking space
provided in the integral garage there's
a condition recommended that make sure
that these two parking spaces to the
slight frontage will be retained in
perpetuity available for the parking of
vehicles generally speaking we accept
and council policy that a single
dwelling house to meet the council's
parking stand it will require the two
bays on bigger sites we require visitor
parking at naught point to five spaces
per dwelling but that's not it's not
general practice to require the visitor
space on a single dwelling house plot
but in any case this site would would
provide and those three spaces but the
two were crucial and they can be
accessed independent of each other okay
Thank You chairman to the fact that the
officer as I mentioned on the 2017 for
refusal of the center of the window
being 45 degrees as the inspector is
already indicated I'd like to put the
motion forward that there is tandem
parking and also the 45 degree does
doesn't is not acceptable in their
legislation we're going to be voting on
the motion for approval as Prince is
next so I think everyone that we've had
a good long discussion on this one so I
think I'm I'm content that we move to
those on this so as mentioned the
approval is label mentioned on 10.1
point 11 is nine points there
so those in favor of the approval if we
go slow myself
Smith for counselor mrs. Shaw for the
count the canal low exclude himself
Cantor FD well that's the eaves
degrading abstain time to mr. Shaw
full-time for Stanley against count the
Western against that's a Williams for
[Music]
welcome games or thank you that's item
is approved cancel Western just very
quickly that play now only approved side
he sees on number three nope element
shall take place in two samples of
mature should be used in the
construction so have they already given
the samples because they've knocked
everything down there any question of
what your house really
that's the Western we we've met we've
made the proper decision if there's
further detail if you wouldn't mind
discussing that with officers after the
meeting now members were at 9:47 not
quite sure how long this next item is
going to take I know I've been having
particularly waiting for this one can I
on a show of hands have your permission
to continue the meeting to the maximum
of a half bath then to get this out the
way the excuse of two minutes because I
need to take some painkillers
okay thank you we will continue the
meeting but when he is briefed two
minute adjournment
you
you
okay
I think wrong we're all and ready - all
ready to go so i from 10.2 this is 66
low around palm bridge this is a
referred item this juror just as a
reminder this is the item that the
addendum refers to which was circulated
so once more Katie Rogers is going to
thank you thank you chairman they
members should see on the screen the
location plan the application cited edge
read although members will note on the
addendum that the site should be edged
only up to this central point here so
the application only extends up to the
point which my cursors showing so that's
approximately half of that what's shown
them ed read on the plan on screen the
site board has lower road to the north
in King's way to the east which is a
private road shown by the cursor along
here the site is currently occupied by a
single-story dwelling I'm shown on these
plans here so my cursor showing you the
floorplan of the dwelling at the moment
and then the elevations though that it's
modest in scale so now on screen you
will see the site plan the proposal is
for a two-story building containing
seven flats the site plan here is
orientated
with lower road to the bottom of the
screen just here on the cursor a parking
area will be provided forward of the
building in this area here shown by the
cursor with an exit only access onto
lower road to the south centrally
positioned the other access would be
provided
to the frontage parking off Kings Way in
this position here in addition to the
parking in addition to the parking to
the front there would be space for some
lansky soft landscaping and a tree
positioned here as shown a second
parking area is proposed to the rear of
the site with further access of King's
way a cycling bin store would also be
positioned to the rear of the site here
the communal amenity space would be to
the rear with a small pride with sorry
in the rear thrown by the cursor in this
location here and then small patios
would also be provided to the
ground-floor flats to the side and to
the front so on screen are the proposed
elevations and floor plans the proposed
elevations if I just point out on the
floorplan show a balcony proposed in
this location here to one of the flats
one here and one to the front these
would be enclosed so they're not
external to the to the wall of the rear
wall of the building and but within so
you wouldn't get significant views out
onto the neighboring amenity spaces
particularly the amenity space that's
closest to the neighboring property as
rear wall the form and appearance of the
building if you look just to the bottom
of the screen would be traditional with
pitched roofs and gable ends
fenestration would have a degree of
symmetry to it
this application follows a 2017
application which was refused and
dismissed on appeal the proposal has
been significantly amended and
importantly the two-story part reduced
in depth adjacent to the boundary with
the neighboring property to the west
this is in this position here so this is
adjacent to the ground floor plan the
first floor plan is also staggered such
that the rear wall here adjacent to this
rear wall boundary of the neighboring
property shown with the cursor here they
would be in line on the previous floor
plan for the refused scheme this wall
projected out a two-story level
this change means that the proposal
would no longer give rise to the degree
of harm the inspector noted would have
been unacceptable in relation to the
earliest scheme the height and massing
of the scheme has also been reduced
significantly and it is considered that
the proposed building would now not
appear out of place in the locality the
building would have much more
traditional form than that previously
proposed I'm just going to sew this 2017
scheme so you can see the design the
formal appearance of the building has
significantly changed the height of this
to the flat roof was nine meters whereas
the proposed building now has roofs
which so reduce the massing and it's not
one sort of flat block and the ridge
heights range from seven point nine to
eight point four meters so they vary
across the eaves on elements of it have
brought much lower those of single
storey level the recommendation is one
of approval subject to the stated
conditions with the following amendments
to conditions and one additional
condition so the amendment to condition
two is simply just to list an additional
plan that should be mentioned and that's
plan number zero 5a the additional
condition is to ensure that the right of
access over the private road Kingsway is
achieved to ensure that the access of
this road would be available in
perpetuity and ensure that the parking
bays could also could all be accessed
but just take you back to the location
plan so we're talking about here and
this point here so this condition would
read prior to commencement of
development hereby approved confirmation
that the two accesses of Kingsway can be
provided and used for vehicles and
pedestrians in connection with the
development hereby approved in
perpetuity shall have been submitted to
and approved in writing by the local
planning authority the development if
approved could not therefore be
commenced unless confirmation was
received that Kingsway as a private road
could be used to access from the parking
spaces
conditions five and six are just to be
beat amended just to note this I'm just
to refer to dwellings in plural rather
than single dwelling as the flats
proposed here and condition eleven is
also to retain a requirements that the
access be completed prior to the first
occupation and also include that these
accesses here off Kingsway be completed
prior to the first occupation and both
retained in perpetuity thank you
chairman thank you we have one short
speaker statement from mr. whaling who's
the applicant and Sonja's going to read
this one out
thank you for this opportunity to
comment prior to your decision on 66
lower road I lived in hockey since 1974
and in lower road hotkeys from 1980 so
I've always had a soft spot for the
Hawks in halbridge areas
I remember this property on the junction
of Surrey Road and lower road as an
electrical shop and later for many years
a bicycle shop both of which are very
useful all those years ago latterly the
building has appeared very tired we
dated
therefore when the opportunity of
purchasing this property arose I had the
idea of building affordable flats of
which there is a shortage in this area
should people wish to remain local ie
first-time buyers or downsizes and to
greatly enhance the overall appearance
of a building in such a prominent
position which were fall in line with a
huge development nearby having taken
into account the advice of the Rochford
planning department I feel that this
third application now meets the criteria
for the local people and RDC
with an attractive building proposal in
proportion to the surrounding dwellings
I await your decision thank you this
item was referred by councillor missus
hi if you'd like to think first
[Music]
you can hear me yeah um yeah I won't
keep you long chairman and I just wanted
to write about the parking yet again
it's too spicy short of the standard 13
spices
and reliable area for buses I don't know
why they keep saying me out into links
because we don't so I just wanted to
raise those points thank you
thank you do any other non-members wish
to see cancer mr. Hoyt
though he has talked about one mutes
there I just wanted a couple of points
read up refer on from castle embassies
or as well with parking in a minute this
application I have to say or not it must
be progressed far better than the one
which was previously put in owned and
refused I still have doubts around
around the scale and the appropriateness
of flats in the area when there are no
flatted blocks in that road at the
moment however I think it's not
something we were unlikely to win on
appeal on that basis however I just sort
of come back for the parking points
again if we can pull up the plans which
came out in the addendum place which
showed the building and particularly
with reference to the two parking spaces
or parking base to the rear of the
property or hope kate is doing there
that the parking spaces generally do
agree to air and parking standards
that's been said that they measure they
basically and they do do meet those
policies however the two parking spaces
to the rear of the property of what a
refer to the park extenders as parallel
spaces so the vehicles are parked
end-to-end where you have intend parking
which is called parallel parking the
spaces are supposed to be six meters
long not 5.5 therefore the space where
that's perfect perfect timing the the
car
pictured there is in a space which
apparently is five point five meters it
should be six meters because obviously
the difficulty of getting out of that
space the first the front space to put
my problem because I assume that X is
spray it onto Kingsway but the car there
is gonna have bushes behind or or
another boundary treatment it has to
have a boundary treatment because that's
amenity space behind and you can't mix
vehicle you can't allow the mixing of
vehicles and amenity space it just can't
happen so that space really should be
six meters long not five point five so
in addition to the the lack of parking
spaces because there is nowhere else to
park there
I think this the additional refusal
should be on the grounds that the
parking Bay which i think is - should be
six meters long in it
addition to that on parking I know we do
have a tendency to reduce parking but I
think we need some consistency the
anchor public house recently provided an
application which was later withdrawn
but we said it wasn't in a main urban
area and therefore we had to have more
parking on it this one beside isn't in a
manor is it a may an urban urban area
there they're a mile apart in the same
village and I'll draw the tension too
far CDM 30 parking standards which says
this document applies minimum parking
standards for residential development
although this may be relaxing
residential areas near town centers and
train stations it's a village not a town
center and we're certainly not near a
train station train stations in Raley
not a whole bridge therefore I think
there are grounds for refusal on on
parking by the number parking spaces the
precedium 13 that there that it
shouldn't be relaxed because we are not
in a Manor in an urban area and there
are no no there is nowhere for vehicles
to power apart from there the W lines on
the road it's just not possible that is
it odd however if you do consider pass
in this could you please add a further
condition or consider adding a further
condition we've had flatted schemes in
the past in whole bridge where they are
two stories high and then later on
they've been built into the roofs to
make them three-story so I'd be take
advice from the the office on this if
you wish but I would like the permitted
development rights removed so that they
can't do their I understand there is
some conditions around they can't extend
with porches which are suitable to the
balconies and but I'd also like the
permitted development rights removed in
a condition if you do pass this so that
they can't build into the roof and make
it three storeys thank you that was yes
cancer mister missus oi so lot my
founder on Park in there I have to agree
with them that it's very bad public
transport ground at the moment
and this one parking space less and as
mr. wurr says it's not up to the length
of the parking spaces so I I find it
difficult I'd find it difficult to pass
this with a parking whereas other places
we've enforced it we should here as well
yes but again I concur with Council
Hawaii and chemistry say about the
parking literally is no infer the
parking room and if we reduce our
standards I think we're storms
Thank You counselor that knowledge is
next make sure everyone said about the
parking need two places on the back
hasn't been pointed out at the moment
use the second parking space actually is
unusable because although even if you do
have the six meters there you still
can't get past it because there wasn't
the car width to be able to get past the
front parking so from the point of view
of that being too useful parking places
in the back it simply isn't the other
thing just to point out the applicants
in the readout he seemed to indicate
that he was keen to do the development
because he would he introduced
affordable housing well there's no
housing it doesn't meet the standard for
affordable housing so I'm not sure where
he comes from on that one I presume that
we are looking at these all being
commercially sold properties if you
couldn't confirm on that please
where we'll gather up everything all
questions in one go
counselor Stanley Thank You German I
just thought - it's already been noted
by all of the counselors but that would
be policy
dm3 and it would be the that would be
knowing in dm3
the availability of sufficient access to
destroy an adequate parking provision
which there isn't
I would also cancel how and as pointed
out that their their tandem parking is
in that the back end of property and the
second car could overtake the first car
because there isn't enough room for that
car to be driven out even to get out of
its square which is you need right angle
driving ability or steering ability and
that Karen and I'm afraid we don't have
that on any car and with that dm3 i
would also like to ask if there has been
any air quality DM 29 and DM 31 on the
provision of movements of course in and
out of that place has there been any
assessment of air quality to their area
and also are we glad to carry that
forward as a motion of refusal please
if you count the western plays yeah I'm
just looking at the on page 10 to 15
about things where as a privately owned
by a family trust what would happen if
that's if they refused permission to use
their the ending podcast and to do the
building works I'd be very concerned
also I'm very concerned with the main
road for the cars and people if this
goes ahead with the cars coming out onto
the front of the whole bridge Road that
roundabout I find it very very very
dangerous so I'm looking to receive this
reason thank you I am reasonably contend
with this one I must admit there have
been a number of application of
variations for this site certainly what
we started with was refused work was far
far too big and dominant and keeping as
a as a gateway building almost all
bridge I think this is much more
reasonable the parking is met there is a
space for each flat how those parking
spaces has managed I don't think
constitutes anything like a reason for
refusal there are conditions clearly
stated that need to be met regarding the
the private road access and the the
development can't go ahead if that isn't
sorted and we also have to remember that
this was a retail unit with multiple
regular accesses to it for many many
years so the principle although we might
not consider it desirable of access on
and around that mini roundabout is long
established and I couldn't see that
holding up so
I think that I'm unreasonably content
with this one chance of Williams I think
you indicated before I go to Katie to
some of the points that have been made
Thank You chairman Katie may we just see
the plan again with the powerful spaces
please yes and there is make thank if
you'd also like to take this opportunity
to sum up the various questions that
have been cuts as well please I think
everyone has had at least one
opportunity to say something before
council Williams asked a question or if
I could just ask them from what you say
is the access to the front parking is
from King's way around the access to the
fronts so to be an exit only access onto
no a road from the parking area at the
front here
and the entry point to this parking area
would be off Kings Way and to that
boundary there and obviously the
application can go through and this they
they they get access to the rear parking
and I'm also looking at Google Maps on
this one again and it's showing a very
wide actually a very wide Kingsway and
on your planet has cars parked in King's
way on the left-hand side is that right
the plant does so just show cars parked
here it's it's informal so when you go
to King's way it's sort of unmade it's
it
there's no demarcation of those parking
spaces on on this on the Kings Way
Street that is all outside of the
application sight boundary so we're only
considering the proposal within the
redline yeah as far as I'm concerned
that's not enforced parking up there on
the left-hand side
it's a private road so um whether you
know people who could enforce any
parking I don't know it doesn't appear
that there's any sort of formal
arrangement or enforcing a parking now
but that I wouldn't say that that's um
key to the determination of this
application
okay fine excellent thank you very much
sure like I want to the other points so
let me go so we have concern raised
about the depth of this parking space
here with this tandem arrangement so it
yes it doesn't meet the six metres but
you could achieve that you would eat
into this amenity space to the rear so
what we would argue is that this these
parking bays would be sufficiently deep
to enable a car to park yes it's a
tandem arrangement but it's the only
tandem arrangement within the site and
tandem arrangements aren't completely or
you know unacceptable we we have
approved them tonight on the London Road
site and there are some tandem
arrangements of parking base there again
this tandem arrangement exits onto a
private drive so it's not onto a highway
which there's significant traffic
flowing along I don't think that
arrangement would be unacceptable I have
a significant concern about any reason
for refused or relating to parking on
this site I think we need to bear in
mind that there's been an appeal and so
there's been two previous applications
one of which has gone to appeal that
appeals scheme was for the same number
of units sorry it wasn't it was forum
eight six two beds and two one beds it
had 13 spaces proposed but it was for
short and so it had a greater proportion
of and to bed properties proposed and
there was no reason for refusal in
relation to the number of parking bays
for proposed in relation to that
previous application and that did not
form part of the appeal so I have a very
significant concern about how we could
reasonably justify a reason related to
in adequate
parking at this site in relation to this
proposal the other question that was
raised with regard to air quality this
site is too small to warrant any
requirement for the applicant to provide
an air quality impact assessment in
relation to the number of vehicle
movements to and from that wouldn't that
that hasn't been required of any
applicant of a scheme that's there's a
quiver listen scale and we'd only look
to sort of really significant
um strategic development sites for that
and the site is not within any air
quality designated management area where
this specific concern about the level of
air quality at present I colleges yes so
flats don't benefit from permitted
development so I'm not concerned about
them being able to alter the roof in any
way okay thank you can I just ask you
through any members who wish to come
back at this moment notwithstanding Kate
is just explaining to us I think it's
important to make sure that the
partnership not just the number of
parking spaces but it's the number of
usable parking spaces and this council
Stanley said and council reins that the
width for those two parking spaces but
there's not actually physically room to
get past the vehicle at the front
okay could I just ask Kate Katie's
opinion that if they cook is the
addition of a condition too long for the
parking space non-material enough to
want the better word to be able to be
added Thank You chairman just share the
screen again so I understand what we're
only talking about this back set there's
a sort of rear element of the site here
in this parking arrangement what we
wouldn't want to happen really is for
the change to the park and arrangement
to impact on the amenity space to the
rear
having said that I think there is
possibly a way that you could achieve
sort of you it would probably require
moving the bins store in the cycle store
so that these were positioned sort of in
this area of the site here with these
two bays adjacent to each other and
you're widening the access point so
you've got two spaces either side of
each other what we need to just be
careful of is that they can get in the
bins wouldn't move significantly just be
odd you just need to be able to put have
access to get the bins out for
collection but would you consider that a
mature a big enough material change for
the application to need to go back to
the the applicants or do you think it is
can you still hear me yeah and I think
that you could impose a condition that
required an amendment to the layout of
the parking bin store and cycle store to
the rear of the site and such that the
two parking bays were adjacent to each
other and I think that could reasonably
be achieved at the site with one
adjacent to each other
I can't scale off this plan right
immediately now I'm if you bear with me
I could scale just to make sure that
this is adequate moment because remember
I'm going to move the approval which is
printed on 10.24 15 there are 17 points
plus there's a good number of
their variations I believe we can put a
condition but an additional condition to
submit layout to deal specifically with
the compliance of the parking spaces as
members have requested can you give us
an answer on the scamming yet
okay see I've got a from two councillors
family plays next Thank You chairman
just to clarify certain conditions
obviously the whole development depends
upon if the owners of the things we will
allow the entrance and what we are
asking is for the double entrance at the
mirror in not a single entrance just a
double entrance and also wherever they
can use it and I don't see how it is
possible to approve the development with
their heart the the actual usage of that
side entrances so they wouldn't be able
to go ahead and offer I forget which
condition it was I think it was
conceived in the addendum that mentioned
that specifically that that that access
needed to be in place before that could
happen
okay see can you come back to us now
yes so I'll just share the screen again
so the distance between the rear
boundary of the site and then upper
botting this source little landscaped
area to the rear of the proposed
building is six approximately six point
nine one meters so you could accommodate
two parking spaces side-by-side that
would have the council's preferred bay
width those spaces would then be no
deeper than this line here where that
existing front bay would extend to and
so you've got I think sufficient space
then to to design a bin store and cycle
store around that so what we would need
to do is just put a condition together
appropriately rated by officers just to
require some not in accordance with this
plan but in a different arrangement to
require all of those things to still be
provided but with the parking in a
side-by-side arrangement the sensible
thing to ask to defer the decision until
we have that in place it does seem to be
a good deal of concern about that
particular aspect I'm not in favor of
the Fairlight I believe we've got
sufficient detail I see a simple
condition that this could be achieved
without the kishi condition being
achieved then the item would need to
come back to us
can I just add one thing just that I
just want to clarify that the
application wouldn't necessarily come
back before members to discharge a
condition but we would be very clear in
the wording of that to seek to achieve
what members are looking for so we would
ask that the parking bays are provided
side by side meeting the base size that
the council has with the bins store
still provided in an ad
in terms of floor you know space for the
bin store and the same cycle provision
but an application to discharge a
condition wouldn't generally come back
for members
okay then well we've heard that I think
I think with all the information on the
discussion we've got we've got enough to
face a decision on so there was quite a
variety to the different conditions that
Katie read at the start
does that does anyone feel that they
need Katie to go over those conditions
again Banyon okay that's good
so the motion is for approval with
variations as stated if I can go go
through this one then please the cell
for counts for mrs. Shaw for Santa Canal
for cancer FD or cancer Gooding
cancel mr. Shaw for cancer Stanley
abstain count the Western exchange at
the Williams approve councillor Eve
8:8 and for extension yeah okay I think
that brings us to the end of the meeting
before we before we go just really do
need to thank cage in particular issues
presented all of these items tonight so
sterling work and as I'm sure a lot of
you can appreciate there's a lot of work
gone on prior to the meeting started and
I think with we made a a good staff and
I think we've made proper proper
decisions tonight so I'm just going to
close close the meeting but if you can
remember if you're going to stay on
weightless on yours confirms that we're
not live streaming before we start any
personal conversations but thank you
very much making close